Поява поліцейських в жовтих жилетах
на громадському заході означає тільки одне:
прибула антиконфліктна група.
Їхнє завдання  - протидіяти масовим заворушенням,
а головний інструмент впливу - не спецзасоби, а слово.
Ми би хотіли з вами з цього приводу поспілкуватися…
...для того, щоб втрішити якось цю ситуацію.
Ні! Ні-ні!
Поліцейські з усієї країни тренуються вести перемовини.
Цьому їх навчають колеги з ЄС.
Серед курсантів лише одна жінка -
Інна Глега з Хмельницького.
Європейські методики їй подобаються.
Нам тут викладали
деякі психологічні основи невербального спілкування.
Вчили, як звертати увагу не лише на те,
що людина говорить, а як вона себе поводить.
Ну, і ми працюємо в  парах.
Одна людина веде перемовини, а інша слідкує за ситуацією,
дивиться, як веде себе натовп.
Антиконфліктні групи  - ще одна складова реформи,
з якою Національній поліції України допомагає
Консультативна місія ЄС.
На думку західних експертів, створення таких підрозділів
в країні, в якій триває війна,
а люди часто виходять на акції протесту,
вкрай необхідно.
Ми повинні враховувати фактор великої кількості
нелегальної зброї, яка зараз на руках в людей.
Також рівень  агресії на демонстраціях.
Ми на власні очі бачили - він ненормально високий.
Але стратегія, яку ми презентували, те, чому ми навчаємо,
які навички передаємо – все це допоможе
в майбутньому впоратися з цією агресією.
Європейські експерти займаються
реформуванням Національної поліції останні 2 роки
та відзначають багато позитивних змін.
За їхніми словами, головне, що нова поліція кардинально
відрізняється від міліції, яка говорила з людьми
виключно мовою сили.
Але претензії до дій поліцейських досі виникають.
І не тільки під час акцій протесту.
Патрульна поліція, так, виконує дуже велику роботу.
А тільки що в районних відділах поліції
залишилися ті ж самі люди.
Це було супер, я був задоволений, що
нарешті в поліцію прийшла реформа.
Я гадаю, що ми не навчені
не так, як громадяни, і не так, як поліція.
Треба вчитися слухати один одного.
Це й стане завданням майбутніх антиконфліктних підрозділів,
які створять в усіх регіонах України.
Перший з них сформують в Києві,
а свої навички з попередження конфліктів він покаже
вже під час "Євробачення".